yo sup hello I saw your posting on
Craigslist for the high/low puppy trike
is that still available yes it is still
available
good how many miles does it have 4 4 is
in 40,000 nope just for mmm has it ever
been in an accident
define accident head-on collisions or
rear on collisions or
no how are the brakes
great can I make an appointment to come
look at that sometime today
oh I mean you can just come whenever I
mean right now or tomorrow or preferably
right now but cash only and no
low-balling here she is really good
get suited up gets the decimal yep
yeah trend looks a little air you want
treads overrated
so you want this or you want this
you know this is the best purchase I've
ever made it's just too bad doesn't have
a radio
it does have a radio it has a keyboard
now what happens did I like not bug free
by just dragging me or what
ah